graduation is highly significant for
young people because it is a death and a
renewal at the same time I mean it's a
good way of learning too about life
because you see when you graduate at
simultaneously you have attained the
pinnacle of something but by the same
token it instantly transforms you into a
beginner at the next stage of your life
when people say what do you want to be
when they grow up in our society they
usually mean what career you're going to
pick it's really not the way the
question should be asked or
conceptualized you should really think
about what sort of character you want to
have I would say you should surround
yourself with people who are aiming up
and who want the best for what's best in
you unless you want people that will
excuse your pathologies and and make way
for your weakness and lead you down the
path of perdition so you're going to
take care of yourself I'm going to take
care of your family you're going to take
care of your community you want to grow
up and be a responsible fourth right and
honest person it's the best way through
life there could be a lot more to you
than you know highly probable and you
should act as if there is and then you
should go out there and try to do if not
great things at least honest productive
meaningful engaged and positive things
that's what you should be aiming at
there's nothing in that except good
you
[Music]